what's really going to happen is the
rule followers might pause might slow
down but the rule Breakers they're only
going to accelerate and that leads to
what I am pretty convinced is the
dystopian state which is the good actors
have worse AIS than the Bad actors but
I'll also talk to The Optimist a little
bit I don't think that means that oh
yeah then we should just relax and just
hope for the best
that might not happen either I think all
of us together have to fight like hell
to make sure that we put the guardrails
we put in when it when the problems
arise reasonable regulations but we
fight like hell for the positive use
cases because very close to my heart and
obviously there's many potential
positive use cases but perhaps the most
powerful use case and a perhaps the most
poetic use case is if AI artificial
intelligence can be used to enhance hi
human intelligence human potential and
human purpose
thank you